Okay, thank you, thank you all for joining the session, so we will be talking about advanced
deep learning basically focusing on natural energy processing aspect of deep learning.
Particularly, we will cover the topics of transformers and BERT, now you have already
gone through certain lectures around NLP and also on deep learning, but I will just give
a brief introduction to the topic before I will talk about the architectures here.
So, what is NLP in general, I mean this is one way we can describe what is NLP, so typically
you want to make computers understand what we are writing or speaking, so think about
doing something for internet web pages, so it is already written by human, so the web
pages you want to summarize that, so you have to first understand what is written and
then you do something like understand what we write and make computers write and also
speaking with that, so this typically covers most of the applications that we have in NLP,
so you want them to understand what we are writing and we also want them to write.
Now, why we talk about NLP, typically we are using NLP in our daily lives and so many applications
so you want to design, implement and test systems that can process natural language
for practical applications and these can be like numerous, you can think about like very
early applications, machine translations and even web search, and to everything around
summarization, question answering, dialogues, classification, there are so many applications
where you would like to process natural language and this would be various practical application
that you can come up with.
Now, depending on the kind of applications that you are targeting there are certain paradigms
that are defined, so for example, it may be about sentiment analysis, so you are given
a piece of text and you want to find out what is the class, so maybe in sentiment analysis
positive negative neutral and text can be the movie review or hotel review, right, news
articles grouping, you are given lot of news articles, you want to group them according
to various topics, so this is again a classification problem, so where you are given a piece of
text and you want to classify into one of the predefined categories, there can be other
paradigm for example, named anti recognition or code mixing part of speech tag where you
are given a sequence and you need to find out what is the tag for each word like in
part of speech tagging I went to the market, for each word you would like to give a tag
like what is I, what is went to the market, for each word you want to define a tag, right,
so this is not open the entire sentence, per word you are defining a tag, so this is what
is called sequence labeling and then there are application where you generate the text
as an output, like machine translation you are given a source language input and you
want to generate something in the target language, translateration, abstract summarization, you
are given an input document, you want to summarize in your own words, right, chatbots, you want
to generate a response, so you are all text generation paradigms, so these are three main
paradigms that we typically talk about in an LP and what kind of methods do we use,
so you see very early methods were like Alizar that was a completely rule based pattern based
chatbot that would converse with people and then slowly there were statistical language
models, we went to Neal probabilistic language models and 2013 was the time when deep learning
really took over in the field of NLT, right, before that we used to develop features for
different problems and use models like SVMs and regression and CRFs, so in 2013 when word
vectors were introduced that is where the field completely changed, so now you can have represent
each word using a vector, right and that was what was used as an input to every other architecture
of deep learning, whether it is recurrent neural networks or the transfer model that
we will talk about, right, so how do you feed the words, you typically take the word embeddings
for that and that is how you feed to the transfer model, so transfer model is one of the main
like you say crucial points in this journey of NLP, so and then into the year 2018-19
the bird came, so this introduced the idea of field training, so you see these are the
two important terms when you talk about GPT, so you have pre-training, you have transformer,
so in GPT P stands for pre-training and P for transformer and G is for generative, right,
so that is where and I mean, so the main advances happen in this field, so we will talk about
transfer model, we will talk about pre-training and GPT models are the generative models,
okay and you all I mean know this field from chat GPT, right, now I am going to when it
was introduced and then I mean, everyone came to know about this field of NLP, large language
models and so on, right and I think this field is moving at a very fast pace, so much and
so now I mean, we do not even interact with the code, I mean we can just interact through
prompts, we can just give a prompt to the LLM like GPT 4 and so on and you can get your
work done, right, so that is why I mean Karpathi had this very famous tweet, the hottest new
programming language is English, so you can simply now prompt in English and you can expect
to get your I mean task done, okay, so before transformers what was the main architecture
that NLP was using, so they were mainly recurrent neural networks in the field of deep learning,
so what is recurrent neural networks, you will feed the words using the word embeddings,
so you feed the embeddings for each word and it will have some identity states, so
you will feed the word embedding, it will go through a hidden state, so you keep on
feeding new words, you keep on getting a recurrent hidden state that captures information up
to that word, so that is what happens and any point of time if you want to get an output,
you apply an output from that, so that is how this paradigm was used for all the different
things, so like if you want to do classification for the antisequence, I will keep on getting
the representation up to hn and then at the final representation, I will apply an output
vector to get the final output, class output, if you are doing sequence labeling, I need
output at every token, so fine I will, for each hidden state, I will apply an output
matrix to get an output, if you are doing language modeling, that is you want to predict
the next word, fine given the previous word, you predict the next word, yeah, and if you
want to do tax generation, I first give my input, get the encodings and using the final
hidden state in general, I use that as a context to start generating my output, so this is
how RNN could capture all of these paradigms, right, using a simplified architecture, and
yeah, 2017 was the time when transformers were introduced and since then they have been
the go-to model for any architecture you can see recently, so this was the paper attention
is all you need from mainly Google brain and University of Toronto, and we will discuss
in detail about this architecture today, so along with transformer, the another model
that, another idea that has become very, very important and prevalent is the pre-training
idea, that I can pre-train in language model using a lot of data and then this can be used
from various kind of tasks, right, so in general, I mean all of these models that you can see
here, like including GPT-3, Palm models, Bloom, Chinchilla and Galactica, OPT and all, so
they are all pre-trained models, and the reason is that I mean, why pre-training is so important
along with transformer because just, it is not that transformers are always better than
RNN, so what made them better was the idea of transfer learning and pre-training, that
you can pre-train a large model, transformer model and then you can use that for variety
of tasks, right, so transformers have become the go-to model for building large pre-trained
language models, which can be adapted for various tasks, and I mean, so we have seen great results
for transformer architecture, so you can see, I mean this is Chatbot Arena, one of the popular
benchmarks of LLMs and the main models from Gemini, Claude and ChatGPT, they are all transformer
based models, including the open source models like Lama 3 from Meta, they are all open source
models, based on the transformer architecture, and it is not that they have worked only for
language domain, they have shown very good results across domains, including say, proteins
modeling, proteins modeling images, systems and different, different kind of data, right,
so they are generalized architecture that can be used for different sorts of data, including
images, audio and so on, okay, so then let us go back to the idea of transformers, so
what is this model, how does it really work, what is the core principles behind this model,
so the main idea behind this model is the idea of attention, right, so we will try to
start defining it very simply and then we will see what is the actual formalism that
the transformer uses for attention, so what is the idea of attention, see in general the
way you can define it, is that suppose you are given a set of vector values, right, so
you have some values v1 to vn, and let us say you have a query, what attention tells
you is a method by which I can use a weighted average of these values dependent on the query,
so I will do a weighted average of v1 to vn depending on the query, right, so if you change
the query from q1 to q2, the weighted average you will get will be different, it is not
a simply an average value of the vectors, you will get a different weighted vector depending
on changing the query, right, so this is the general idea of attention, so this weighted
sum you can think of it as a selective summary of the information that is contained in the
values, right, and where the query will find out where to focus on, right, and another
way you can see, see this n is not important, you can have a 5 different values, you can
have 10 different values, 20 different values, so you can have an arbitrary set of representations,
and this gives you a way in which you can get a fixed size representation from that,
right, so this n is not important, n can be 10, 20, 50, 100, but I can still get a fixed
size representation out of that, right, so this is another very important point about
attention, now yeah we will come back to this, I mean how exactly attention works, so why
is attention is the model that people consider, because in recurrent new networks what used
to happen, so let us say this is the input, you are giving some input, so x 1 to x n,
what you get, you get the hidden states h 1 to h n, I get hidden states corresponding
to each word, and this hidden state captures information up to that particular word, right,
the problem with this architecture was that I cannot compute h 2 unless I have h 1, right,
so to get the hidden state of h 2 I need to have the hidden state of h 1, so there is
a dependency, so I cannot compute all h 1 to h n in parallel, I have to do it sequentially,
I will first compute h 1, use that to compute h 2 to h 3 and so on, so it is always sequential
computation, but we know I mean when deep learning what is important is that to do things
in parallel, you have to parallelize the things, so how do I ensure that I can still compute
the representations for each word in parallel, right, and that is what was achieved through
attention as we will see, so here I cannot compute a future RNA identity state unless
I compute the past RNA identity states, right, so there is a dependency involved in RNA's,
now transformer we will see, we will try to remove the dependency, how exactly we will
do that, let us understand it, so what is a transformer architecture, so it was introduced
in this paper as an encoder-decoder architecture, later on we will see, you can use it simply
as an encoder, also simply as a decoder, right, so that is not so important, so it understand
what is the core ideas behind this architecture, so this is a transformer and you can think
of it as encoder-decoder architectures right now and later we will see encoder only and
decoder only transformers also, so what does encoder do, right, what is the task of encoder,
so we will use encoder-decoder whenever our task involves an input sentence, right, so
this is an input sentence in French and I want to generate some text, right, so this
can be translation, this is in another language, same English, so encoder will take the French
sentence here and decoder will generate the English translation, now what is the task
of the encoder, the task of the encoder is that it produces a very good representation
of the input, so that means at the end, if you think of it as a black box, what you want
to get are some good representations of the 3 words that you have provided as input, right,
so this is what encoder will do, so a sophisticated representation of the source sequence, right,
now this is what the decoder will focus on generate its output, so the decoder will use
these representations to be able to generate its output, so I am a student, right and decoder
in transformer generates output one word at a time, so I will first generate i, it will
feed i here, generate m, feed m, generate a and so on and this is what we will typically
call as auto-aggressive generation, I generate one word at a time, so this is what typically
transformer decoder architecture looks like, now when we say encoder, decoder it is not
a single layer, so you will have like multiple layers of encoders, multiple layers of decoder,
so in the original transformer paper, so there were 6 encoders and 6 decoders, what it means
there are 6 layers of encoders, 6 layers of decoders, okay, now we will understand the
one particular layer, right and we will see the other layers are just a copy of that different
weights, they do the same task, so what is one particular layer, so this is like one
encoder layer, what actually happens in that one encoder layer, so I feed the words, how
do I feed the words, I feed the words through embeddings, what are embeddings, they are
dense representations of the word that captures semantics, so two similar words will have
similar vectors, right, so I feed the embeddings for thinking and machines as the input, the
first thing that happens in a layer, transformer encoder layer is that self-attention, so attention
will ensure that the word thinking gets context of all the other words in the input and gets
a good representation, context of representation, so this is the representation for thinking,
similarly the machines will get the representations by looking at the surrounding words, so we
will get the representation for machines, now this is the self-attention output, to that
we apply feed forward neural network, okay, so we apply feed forward neural network that
is the second thing that happens and we get the output of feed forward neural network,
right, now there are certain things that are maintained in this, for example, let us say
I feed a 512 dimension embedding, so this is 512 dimension, so I always maintain these
dimensions whenever I have an output of a block, so that means this will also be 512
dimension, this will also be 512 dimension and how does it help because now you see this
output will become the input to the next layer, so to the second layer the input becomes this
particular output of the first layer, it is the input to the next layer, so that means
you have, you do not have to worry about thinking different dimensions of matrices across layers,
you have the same dimensions in all the layers, so 512 dimension input across all the layers,
512 dimension output across all the layers, what you can vary is this 512, this is what
we will define as a model dimension, so you can say I will use 1024, 768, I will vary
this model dimension, fine everything else will change according to that, right, so this
is what happens, right, so in the first layer you have the static token embeddings but then
you get a representation through the processing of any layer and that becomes the input to
the next layer and this keeps on happening across layers in the transformer, okay.
Now let us go back to adhesion again, like what is the intuition, so think about the
sentence, the chicken didn't cross the street road because it, right, now what should be
the properties of it, what should be the representation for it, now it itself does not tell too much
unless you know what it refers to, right, so suppose I have two different sentences,
two different completions because it was too tired, it was too wide, right, so what do
you see now, so in the first sentence the it should refer to too tired should be the chicken
and too wide should be the road, right, it should represent the chicken enrolled in the
two sentences, so and that is what you want to know, I mean in the self-adhesion you want
to know which word I should focus on in the entire sentence, right, so that I can get a
good representation of myself, otherwise it itself may not be sufficiently to tell you
whether it refers to the chicken or the road, right, so you need that contextual representation
for this, so this is what attention will do, it will build up a contextual embedding of
a word by selectively integrating information from the surrounding words, right, and this
is what we will say, a word attends to some neighboring words more often than others,
so it is not a simple weighted average, I mean simple average of all the embeddings,
it will see which word I should attend more on, right, we should, what I will focus more
on to get a contextual representation, okay, and this is what the blog from Google showed,
this was a picture from the blog itself, so they showed this actually happens, so suppose
this is your layer K of the transformer and this is layer K plus 1, so in the layer K
plus 1 the next layer it was found the word it referred to chicken in this case, it was
too tired it actually referred to the chicken, right, more than the road, and this is what
I mean was the ideal case, let us see another intuition for self-attention, right, so you,
so now we will talk, introduce one more thing, so till now we talked about using a query
we will take a weighted average of the values, but we use something else called key, so it
has a key value and query, right, and this is very similar to what we do in retrieval
system, so let us take a scenario, suppose you are searching for videos on youtube, right,
so what you do you give a query, so you have a query that you type in the search bar, now
how do you, how does the search work, typically each video, so in some video you call them
the value, right, but the way search happens there are certain metadata with the video,
for example the title of the video, description, call that the key of the video, so each video
will have some metadata, say the key and its corresponding value, so k1v1, k2v2, k3v3
across videos, so when you search what happens, you do not search with the values directly,
you search with the keys, you match the query with the metadata, and let us say you find
out this has the highest match, what you will do, you will retrieve the value v2, right,
you will retrieve the value, or let us say somebody says you make a summary video from
all of these, what you will do you say, which of these key has the highest value, let us
say key 2 has a score of 0.8, k1 has a score of 0.1, and k3 has a score of 0.1, so what
I will do I will take 80% of video 2, 10% of video 1, 10% of video 3 and create a summary,
right, out of that, now that is what actually happens in attention, so you have query, you
have a set of keys, set of values, you match the query with the keys, you find which key
has the highest match with the query, and you will give a more weightage to its corresponding
value, right, so this is a very good way to understand self-attention, so this is what
will happen, so this word, we will have a query from this word, and all the words, they
will, you will have a key as well as value for each word, right, and what you will do
this query will, you will find a similarity of this query with all the keys and then take
a weighted average of all the values, right, so each word will have a key and a value,
okay, now how, in mathematical form, how does this attention really work, so now let us
look into the detail, right, so we talk about theory, query, key and value, right, but what
we have at our disposal right now is only the embedding, so when we have a word like
chicken or the road, I only have the embeddings of that word, right, whatever I mean 512 dimension
or whatever I choose as the model dimension, they will have some representation, right,
now I want to use that to get all these query key and value, now how do I get that, right,
so generally what is done, so say, okay, I want to use the same embedding to get query
key and value, so fine, I use a learnable projection matrix to convert this into query
key and value, so I learn three different projections, one is query matrix, key matrix
and value matrix, three different matrices, right, so what will, what will happen with
the query matrix, so say, my xi is 1 cross 512 and wq is 512 cross 64, I will get a 64
dimension representation, right, so I multiply the embedding with this projection matrix,
so that I can get a query, same way, this is 1 cross 512 and this may be 512 cross 64,
I get again another 64 dimension representation, 1 cross 512, 512 cross 64, I get 1 cross
64 dimension representation, so that means I need three different learnable matrices
that will convert my embeddings into query key and value for each word, so that means
I will get this query key and value differently for each word because they depend on the embeddings
and then they are multiplied with the three matrices, query key and value matrix, okay,
so that means I have now three representations for a same word, query key and value, right,
now see we want, given a word you want to focus on any neighboring word, so, so current
element xi would like to find its similarity with qj, so what is done, so I want to find
similarity of current element with everything else, so I generate the query from here, so
query is used from here and from the jth word I use the key and value, so kj and vj comes
from here, right, query comes from the word that you want to match with everything else
and for every other word you will get the query and the key and the value, right and
how do you find similarity, you can simply use a dot product, so I find qi times kj is
the dot product and each summing of xj we will sum up vj, we will take a weighted average
of vj, right, now let us look at it like it from an example, so suppose you sentences
the beetle drove off, so what I do I first get the embeddings for each word, I have
the embedding for the embedding for beetle, embedding for drove, embedding for off, then
what I will do, I will multiply these embeddings with the three matrices, query key and value,
you see the same matrix across all the words, for all the words, so I do not have different
query key value for each word, right, for all words we have the same matrix, so find
I will multiply the embedding with this matrix and I get k1, sorry q1, k1, v1, q2, k2, v2,
q4, k4, v4, I get the query key and value for all the words, right, this is the first
step that I do, next let us say I am interested in one word, so my focus is on the word beetle,
so I will use beetle to find the selective summing from all the neighbors, so where will
my query come from, query will come from beetle, right, this will be my query and they will
my keys come from, because I want to match similarity of query with all the keys, keys
will come from all the words in the sentence, so this will be k1, even including this word
k2, k3, k4, so I find similarity of q with k1, k2, k3 and k4, this is the next step
I do, okay, then what I want to add finally as the output the values, right, remember
the idea of searching on YouTube, so I want to compare my query with all the metadata,
the keys, then whichever has the highest similarity I take corresponding value, now what may happen
when I do similarity, similarity can be a cosine similarity, this can be in the range from minus
1 to 1, right, so I can get a similarity like 0.8, 0.9, minus 0.2, 0.5, so how do I use
them to get a weighted average of the values, right, now sometimes they are negative and
sometimes positive, right, so what I do I convert them to a probability distribution,
so that I can convert, I can my weights are all positive and they add up to 1, so how
do I convert any real numbers, a set of real numbers into a probability distribution, so
they are very standard take that we use in deep learning, it is a softmax take, so what
is softmax I will simply take e to the power 0.8, e to the power 0.9, e to the power minus
0.2, e to the power 0.5, you know once we put exponential to the power something it
is all positive, right, so they are all positive things and then because they would not add
up to 1 as it is, so I divide by this normalization, summation of all these values, right, I add
over all the values, right and that is all, so I have this attentionist course, right,
the similarity for each word divide by similarity for all the words, but exponential, softmax.
So lambda 2, lambda 3, lambda 4 now are all greater than 0 for sure and they will add
up to 1, now that we have this lambda, I will take a weighted average of all the values
that will be my self attention output, so I will take a weighted average lambda i v i
of all the 4 values and that will give me the output, this is the output for this word.
Now, now coming back to the question, right, remember in what we said, given a word its
hidden representation cannot be completed in parallel, so you have to first compute
h 1, use that to compute h 2 and so on, can you do in parallel and transformers, yes,
because there is no dependence between how you compute the output of beta versus how
you compute the output for the, because for output of the you will take the query from
the and you will multiply with the keys for all other words, right and this has no dependence
on whatever you are doing with the beta, so you can do attention self attention computation
in parallel for all the words, right. So, I can in parallel compute all the self attention
because they do not interact with each other, right, so that is why this is very, very efficient
you can parallelize this operation. Now in equations, I mean this has been called
as one of the most important formula in deep learning, like since 2017, 18, so what you
do in terms of equation, fine, from each word you have the embeddings, now you multiply
these embeddings with these 3 matrices query k and value, now for 2 words x i and x j what
is the attention score, you take the query from x i, you take the key from x j and multiply
them, now there is also a normalization that happens that is divided by square root of
d k is called a scaling factor, what is d k dimension of the keys, right, we will discuss
briefly why we divided by square root of d k, but we divided by the square root of the
dimension of the keys, right. And now once I have the score for x i, x j,
I use that to compute my final softmax, so I use a score, take a softmax over all the
scores of x i with all the other words and compute the attention and then I take a weighted
average of all the values, sigma alpha i j v j, this gives me the attention output for
the word x i, right, left just shows a very nice tweet telling the equation like one of
the most important formula in deep learning, okay, now let us try a problem, so this becomes
very clear to you, so let us say we have 2 words flying an arrow and you are given some
6 dimension embeddings for each, right, so flying has 6 dimension vector, arrow also
has a 6 dimension vector, suppose you want to use self-prediction to represent the word
flying, right, in the first encoder, now see to represent this I need to know what is my
projection matrices, the w, q, w, k, w, what are my 3 projection matrices, now in this
toy example we have taken a very simplistic way that is for the first attention had the
query key and value are just the 2 dimension from the input, so I will take the first
2 dimension this becomes my query, right, so my q 1 is simply 0, 1, my k 1 is simply
the next dimension that is 1, 1, v 1 is 1, 0, similarly q 2 is 1, 1, k 2 is 0 minus 1
and v 2 is minus 1, right. Now, so this is the first step you need, right,
you need to get that query key and value, now you can also ask me what was the corresponding
matrix w, q such that you get this, right, so what will be that, so this will be you
have this let us say the first one 0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 0, so this is 1 cross 6 and you want
to get a 2 dimension output you have to multiply the 6 cross 2 matrix, right, because this
matrix is ensuring that you take the first 2 dimensions only, so what should be that
the values, so you can work it out it will be 1, 0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, so
that when you multiply what will be the output, here you take just the first dimension that
is where you have the 1 and then you take the second dimension that is where you have
the 1, so answer will be 0 and 1 that is my q 1, right, that is the matrix in this particular
toy example. Now, so once you have the query key and value
for both the words, what is the next step, what do you want to do, I want to get the
self-condition output for the word flying, the first word, right, so what do I need,
I need query for this word, I need key for both the words, I need value for both the
words, right, if I have that I can compute the output, so let us see, so we have this
is the query for the word and these are the 2 words, the keys for both the words and these
are values for both the words, so how does it work, so let us say you are doing scaling,
so let us compute, so we have query 1 dot k 1 divided by square root of dk, so what
is dk dimension of the key, that is 2, right, so q 1 dot k 1 will be 0 times 1 plus 1 times
1, 1 divided by square root of 2, fine, what will be q 1 dot k 2, so q 1 dot k 2 will be
minus 1 by square root of 2, right, so you have 2 different outputs, the dot product outputs,
what you will do next, you convert them to softmax, you take a softmax over this, so
this will be roughly 0.7 and minus 0.7, so you take e to the power 0.7, e to the minus
0.7 divided by e to the power 0.7 plus e to the minus 0.7, right, and you get 2 values
x 1 and 1 minus x 1, they will add up to 1, right, you can compute what is x 1, so you
get 2 values, x 1 1 minus x 1, right, they will add up to 1, now what is x 1, you try
to compute, now what is my output for the first foot, I will take a weighted average
of the values, what are the weights, x 1 times v 1 plus 1 minus x 1 times v 2, this will
be x 1, first dimension will be x 1 minus 1 minus x 1, second dimension will be just
1 minus x 1, that will be the output, right, if once you get the value of x 1, you can
get the final output of your attention, that is your a 1, this is how the attention works,
right, and this you can do for the second word also, you can now take the query from
second word, key from both the words, you can compute, you get the output, what will
be a 2, so you try this on your own, ok, now given this idea of attention, what is the
next thing, so how does, so we have, so now coming back to the whole picture, we are still
talking about the first encoder of transformers, we are trying to understand how does the self
attention work, right, so we talked about self attention, but in general what is done,
you have multiple hats for self attention, right, so this is called multi hat attention,
so what it means is that you do not just work with a single set of query key and value matrices,
you have multiple set of query key and value matrix, so you can have one set hat 1, attention
hat 1, WQ1, WK1, WV1, you may have attention hat 2, which is WQ2, WK2, WV2, a separate
set of the query key and value matrices and so on, whatever hat K, WQ, KWK, KWUK, right,
you may have K different hats, so K different tuples of this query key and value matrices,
and that means that also means I will get different outputs from each of these, so here
this may be the output from the first hat, second hat and up to whatever the last hat,
so how do I use that together to make a final representation, very easy, I will say I simply
concatenate, concatenation means just putting them one after another, so one after another
I put them, so let us say each of these output, what is the dimension for each of the output,
what am I doing an average of, I am doing an average of all the values, so each output
is of the dimension of dV, right, and let us say we have h attention hats, so dV times
h, so this output is of dimension h times dV, now remember I have to always convert them
output into the same model dimension D that I started with, if this was D I have to bring
it back to D, that is why I have another matrix WO that will take this h dV back to D, so
this WO dimension is h dV times D, h dV times D, so it will convert it back to the D dimension
output of self-denial, so you may have this question like why do we need to do multi hat
attention, why cannot we simply use one hat, so we talked about one generation hat, WQ,
KW, why do we need to have multiple copies, the reason typically this is seen in deep
learning I mean, so if you have just one way of projection here, forces the model to only
find one way in which you can project an input to query gain value, you can only focus on
one aspect, right, so what if I want to look at multiple present the sentence at once on
different different aspects, right, let us say for bird eye, I may want to focus on differentiate
for different regions, so for all these different regions we will try to define different of
Q, K and V matrices, right, and each attention hat performs the computation independently
and then output of each hat, all the hats are combined by concatenation, so each hat looks
at different things, for example this paper I tried to do this analysis that they can
be hats, for example positional hats that will simply look at the neighbors, they will focus
more on the neighbors, there are syntactic hats that will point to tokens with a specific
syntactylation like a word may focus on the subject or an object and so on, adjective
to add to the noun and so on, and they can be hats that point to the rear words in the
sentence, so you can have different hats that have different tasks, and that is why your
each of the projection matrices are independent, so you have WQ1, WK1, WV1 for head 1, and
another hat you can have WQI, WKI, WVI, right, so you can have different attention hats different
matrices for that, they are all variable parameters, so how does it look like, so you see I start
with the 1 cross D dimension input embedding, right, the input, and I have it for all the
words in the sentence, for different attention hat I compute WK1, WV1, WQ1, head 1, head
2, WK2, WV2, WQ2, and by that I get an output, so I have an output for the first hat 1 cross
DV, second hat 1 cross DV, head 8, 1 cross DV, each hat I have output of 1 cross DV dimension,
so together I concatenate all of these, I get a 1 cross HDV output, dimension output,
now I want to convert it back to D, so I have a matrix WO that is HDV times T that converts
it back to 1 cross DV, you see I come back to the same dimension as my input, and this
is the output of self-admission block, so we have many linear parameters, all of these
WKW, QW, WV across all the hats are learnable, and this final WO is also linear parameters,
right, so now if you try to find out I mean more on dimensions, in the original transform
paper the D was 512, the modern dimension was 512, the query key in value each was 64
dimension each, right, that means what is the dimension of WQ1, that will be 512 cross
64, same with WKWB, right, for each hat the output is DV dimension, that is 64 dimension,
and I had 8 attention hats that means totally this output is 512 dimension, now what will
be the dimension of W2, WO this will be 512 cross 512, now if you try to find out what
are the number of parameters I need here, let us see what are the number of parameters
I need a single encoder, number of parameters for self-admission, so let us say I have a
model dimension D, so D is my model dimension, so H is the number of attention hats, and
let us say DQ, DK, DV are the dimensions of query key in value, for simplicity what is
done, so we take DQ as DK as DV as DYH, generally that is what is done, okay, but in general
you do not need to ensure this, because you are taking a dot product of Q and K, so Q
and K should always be the same, but you are allowed to use a different DV, but I mean
that will just complicate the things, so by default they are all kept the same as DYH,
so now how many parameters you need, you have H attention hats, for each of the attention
hat you have 3 matrices, query key in value what are the dimensions of these, D times
D by H, right, plus you have a WA matrix that take H times DV times D, right, so what is
it come out to be, so this is 3D square plus H times DV, DV is D by H, H times D by H cross
D which is also D square, so totally there you have 4D square parameters for self attention
and D is 512 if you take D is equal to 512, if you take D is equal to 512, 512 cross 512
will be like 2.25 million into 4, roughly 1 million, so roughly you have 1 million parameters
if you have model dimension as 512, in just the self attention 1 million parameters, fine,
now what next, so what you did, you took the input embeddings and used the neighboring
words to get a self attention output, but till now there are no non-linearities that you
did, they are all linear transformation that you did, so self attention is simply performing
a re averaging of the value vectors, nothing else right, you are doing a re averaging of
the value vectors by different ways, so how do I introduce some non-linearities, so typically
what is done, once you have the output of self attention, you apply a feed forward model,
feed forward layer to the output of attention and that will give a non-linear activation,
so how is it done, so let us say this is the self attention output, so D dimension output
of self attention, you apply an up projection, so you have an up projection, then you apply
a non-linearity and then you have a down projection and this dimension is same as D, that is what
is done, so let us say you need two matrices to go from the self attention output to the
hidden layer and then another matrix W to go to hidden layer to the output of feed forward,
so what are the dimensions of each, typically by default this W 1 is 4, I mean, so you have
this 1 cross D and you do D cross 4 D, so you take it to 4 D dimension right, 4 times
dimension of the original input and then W 2 is again 4 D cross D, bring it back to D
dimension right, there are some bias terms that we are not considering too much here,
so how many parameters you need, W 1 is D cross 4 D, 4 D square and W 2 is again 4 D
cross D, that is 4 D square, totally you need 8 D square parameters right, so 1 million
in the self attention and roughly this will be roughly 2 million, so that means each encoder
block needs roughly 3 million parameters right, with a model dimension of 512, okay, now the
next problem that comes in fine, I am doing it, I have multiple layers in the encoder,
how do I ensure that this will work seamlessly and I do not come up with various issues when
I train with deep networks, so there are various tricks that I use, so like in CNNs it was
found when you increase the layers, it does not work and that is why you have to do some
skip connections, residual connections, so you apply this trick also to transformers,
the residual connections and because you do residual connections, you do skip connections,
you have to normalize again, so you do layer normalization and then you have the scale
dot plot attention that we anyway talked about, so let us see the tricks briefly, so first
is the residual connection, so what is the idea, so you see what is happening, you take
the original embedding, at the self attention you get the output of self attention, so this
is the embedding and you have the self attention output right, self attention output of X i,
this is your X i and then you want to directly apply feed forward, so in residual connection
you avoid that what you say okay, I will add X i to this, so that is why you have an add,
so plus X i, this is called skip connection, you add this input back and this is what is
become the input to the next block, so this gives you a skip connection, a direct connection
from the input to here right by doing this addition, otherwise you may have completely
lost this input, you have simply take a self attention, but you have forgotten the original
input embedding, so this will add the original input embedding to this and now to this you
apply the feed forward right, so this is the addition, so you do the addition of the input
and you keep on doing it, so once you have some vector here, you get the feed forward
on this, you again add back this chip, so this in principle what it is doing, the original
input is going directly to the last layer right and this keeps on happening every layer,
so you have this addition, this is your connection part in transformers and this also prevents
network from forgetting the original embedding, because you are feeding it back right, as
X i is just a transformation, you are feeding the original input again adding to that okay,
then what is the second trick, because you are doing addition, so what may happen you
keep on increasing the values right, you are keeping original the output of self attention,
you add X i to that, so you keep on increasing the values, so you somehow have to bring them
back to the some standard mean and standard deviation, so this is done by layer normalization
right, so you because the input they keep shifting, you are adding the input again and
again, so you the mean and value standard deviation will keep on shifting, so the solution
is that you can normalize to 0 mean and standard deviation always, so once you do addition
you again come back to 0 mean and standard deviation and the idea is very simple, you
take all the vectors, find the mean, find the standard deviation and then given a vector
you say okay, I will subtract the mean and divide by the standard deviation plus an epsilon,
so that there is no whenever they are all uniform, you are not dividing by 0, this is just a
small positive quantity, to avoid division by 0 right, so you do that and you get the
output self attention output, I mean the output at every layer after normalization, subtract
the mean divide by the deviation and you get the output okay, so suppose you are like mean
this are the values, what you will do, you will take the mean of each, you will take
the mean, you will take the standard deviation and then what will be the corresponding output
after normalization, you will say okay 1 minus the mean 4 divide by standard deviation right,
for this 3 minus 4 divide by 2.03, 5 minus 4 divide by 2.03, so you will take them to
some very mean 0 standard deviation 1 right and you work with that, so that even you keep
on adding the input, you are bringing them back to mean 0 standard deviation, it becomes
easy to train your model, so these are the tricks that I used when you train large models
and then you do scale dot product attention, so what is that, so you have, remember we
talked about q i dot k j divide by square root of d k right, so why do you need to divide
by square root of d k, so idea is this that okay, your q i and k j had let us say they
were mean 0 standard deviation 1, I want to ensure that the value I get as a real to dot
product is also mean 0 standard deviation 1 right, but that does not happen right, so
when you do q dot k, so what is q dot k, q dot k is q 1 k 1 plus q 2 k 2 and so on.
Now if its mean is again 0, because if you once you take an expectation of this, this
will be expectation of q 1 k 1 plus q 2 k 2 and they are independent, so you say expectation
of q 1 times expectation of k 1 which are both 0, this is fine, the problem comes in
the variance, so what will be variance, this will be expectation of q dot k square minus
q dot k square minus expectation of q dot k square right, variance is expectation of
x square minus expectation of x square, now expectation of q dot k is 0, so this comes
terms out to be 0, but what is expectation of q dot k square right, now q dot k square
will have terms like q 1 square k 1 square up to q n square k n square plus cross terms
to q 1 k 1 q 3 k 3 like that right q i, so these cross terms will all go to 0 when you
do expectation, but expectation of each of these is 1 right, so then what will happen
because this is the variance, so one you keep on adding 1, how many times as the dimensions
are there in q and k right, that is why this instant division becomes the variance becomes
dk dimension of the key, you could have also said it as dq dimension of query because they
are the same, now you want to bring it back to variance 1 what you have to do divide by
square root of dk, so once you divide by square root of dk what will happen, so q 1 square
k 1 square divide by dk right, so you will have 1 by dk 1 by dk dk times you get a variance
of 1 right, that is the essential idea of dividing by square root of dk okay, so now
let us we are ready to look at the entire transfer block, so we start with the words
the beetle drove off, we get the embeddings for each word, I apply multi hat self-attention
which will give me the same dimension output, next I do skip connection, I add it back right,
so I have the skip connection and because I am doing adding this back residual connection
I have to normalize it, so I have a layer normalization right and this will become the
input to my feed forward network, so I apply feed forward layer here, again I do the same
thing I do a skip connection, I do a normalization layer normalization right, so this I have
to keep on repeating this every time I do an operation, so I do a skip connection, I
do a normalization, now this is where I get the output of the first layer, so this is
from the first layer right and this will become the input to the second layer right and so
on and then the second layer will process similarly with different set of weights and
the output of the second layer will become the input to the third layer right, so this
is one way you can see it it transform a block, you get the embeddings, you apply self-attention
layer, you add the original input back and normalize and then you apply feed forward
to this, add it back and normalize right, so this is how you can see the all the operations
in a transformer and go to block okay, so this is how an complete transformer block
looks like, now there is still a major problem, I hope you can spot that, so that is right
now the representation of a beetle we know this can be computed in parallel right for
all the words, but it does not depend on position, if I change the position of the words I permute
them and I say drove of the beetle I will get the same representation for all the words
right, so it does not depend on the position of the each word in the sentence, so the order
does not matter here, so how do I bring in the position of a word into the picture right,
so what do I need to do so that the position also becomes important right and comes into
consideration, so that is why we introduce the position encoding of the words, so what
I will do I will have the word embedding plus I will add some additional information that
will tell me what is the position of that word, so I explicitly encode the position
information of the words, so that when I am taking dot products and everything I know
okay I am taking a dot product of the word that is three positions before me or two positions
after me and so on right, so I add a fixed quantity to the embedding activations and
is what I call as the position embedding okay, now how do I compute this position embedding
I mean there are various ways of doing that the original transformer paper said okay you
can use some sign and cosign of different periods, now what is the idea, so you see first of
all what how many values do you need for position embeddings, so there will be something like
how many positions a model can support, let us say model can support up to 512 positions
I have position 1, 2, 512 right or let me call it a different value, so let us say 500
positions a model let us say can only support up to 500 positions right, then in each position
I have a embedding right, so in each position I have 512 dimension embedding, so that means
I need 512 cross 500 parameters as a position embedding parameters, each position in each
dimension of them any what should be the value, so there are two things one is the position
second is the dimension, so what was the trick that they followed they said okay for each
dimension I will use a separate sine wave or cosine wave right, so this is like for dimension
4 I will follow this wave, dimension 5 I will follow this wave, dimension 6 I will follow
this wave, dimension 7 yeah whatever I mean each dimension have a separate wave with different
period right, alternatively sine and cosine, so in one position sine, cosine and non right
the dimension right, so dimension is done what will I do of the positions right, so
for each dimension I will have a separate wave, so this is like let us say these are
the 512 dimensions of the ith words position embedding, but how will the across positions
how will the values change across position 1 to 500, so this is okay you just take the
value of this embedding different position this is let us say I am focusing on dimension
4 right, at position 1 I will take its value, position 2, position 3, position 4 and so
on, position 20 right, so I will sample this wave at different positions I will get the
value and now you can do the same for all the other waves, so at position 20 what is
the value of dimension 5 this is the value, dimension 4 this is the value, dimension 7
is the value and dimension 6 this is the value right, so you have this 500 plus 512 things
by taking different waves for different dimensions and sampling at different positions right,
so you get this 500 plus 512 thing, 512 other dimensions and 500 are the number of positions
right, it is starting from 01 to 499 and so on, so I have this matrix completely decidable
I mean you completely know this matrix by this particular form, so you fix those right,
now one can also say fine like this is one way but I can also learn them like what is
the best possible position embeddings, so later models also try to learn this, so what
you can do you can learn a position embedding matrix right of shape 1 cross n right and
so each position you have a 1 cross n that is 512 dimension embedding and you learn it
for all the positions that you need, so that means you can have 500 cross 512 as the additional
level parameters and that means once I train it with the model, the model tells you what
are the best values of these positions and the word fish for example, if it comes at
position 3 versus position 17 I can have different embeddings, position embeddings for that right,
so that means what will happen finally for each one I will have the word embedding, I
will have the position embedding right and then I simply add them, so take a word like
thinking machines, I take the embedding for the word plus I add the position embeddings,
I get this as the input to the block and then I apply my normal self-attention, air normalization
feed forward and this is my output, so you apply position embedding only at the layer
1 input, you do not need to apply it again and again right and this can be either learned
or you can use some tricks like sinusoidal embeddings. So now, so this is how you can
see a transfer with two encoders, you can put the output here as the input to the next
encoder and so on, you can have 6 encoders, 12 encoders and so on and then I can now start
applying the decoder also to that right, so this is now the encoder block and this is
the decoder block, decoder block is slightly different, I mean nearly the same there are
certain changes that you have that you will see in decoder compared to the encoder right,
so how is the decoder different, so I think we will see that after a small break, so we
will take a small break now and after the break we will come back and start understanding
what is a decoder architecture and transformer, how it is different from the encoder that
we have seen till now okay, yeah we will come back after the break, so till now what we
have discussed the transformer encoder architecture, so where the main modules for multi head self
attention and a feed forward network, of course we had other things like add and normalize,
we had the position embeddings right and together defines my encoder and we saw this
as roughly 4d square plus 8d square, so that is 12d square parameters per layer and each
layer will have same number of parameters, so if you want to find out number of parameters
in an encoder you can simply say 12d square into number of layers right, like if you take
the original transformer, so you will have 3 million into 6, so 18 million parameters
in just the encoder right, now how is decoder different right, I mean if you see here the
decoder has 3 things, self attention looks similar, feed forward looks similar, but there
is one extra thing called encoder decoder attention, why, because what is the task the
decoder, see encoder will finally produce some contextual representation of the input,
the decoder is supposed to look at that right and produce its output, at the same time it
will also look at its previous word that they generated, that is why you had 2 attention,
one is to focus on only the previous generation and second to focus on the encoder representation,
that is why you have 2 different attention here, self attention and also encoder decoder
cross attention and after that you do for feed forward right, so even in self attention
there is slight change why, because when you are training you want to feed do things in
parallel right, so what you will do, so I will feed the word like I am a student, this
in your generation I am a student, so you know this is what you have to generate right,
so and you want to start computing a loss in the decoder, so decoder will anyway do its
self attention and everything feed cross attention, feed forward layer by layer, finally at the
last layer you will generate some cross entropy loss, you will have cross entropy loss, what
is that minus log probability of the next token say m, cross entropy loss minus log
probability of the next token that you want to generate and you know what is the token
I have to generate anyway at the training time, so this phenomena as you know is called
teacher forcing, so you force the ground to token to be the input to the next, so that
means you already know what is the input to an entire sequence right, so just like encoder
I could compute in parallel right, I do not have to do one by one, so I can compute everything
in parallel at the training time because I know the entire sequence at the input, so
I can compute in parallel all the representations, the problem there is the different thing I
have to do here is, if I know that the next word is a and my task is also the next word
is a does not make sense, so at m if I know my next word is a through position I am reading
and I have to predict the next word as a that means I already have information I can I am
not learning much, so I have to somehow ensure that the transfer model does not look at the
future words right, I mean it only looks at the current word and the previous words that
is all in the decoder, so the only thing you do in the decoder in the attention is that
I do not allow the any token to look at the future tokens and everything else is same,
so how do you do that you say ok I have this attention matrix, so let us say I have attention
matrix square matrix each word I which word j it can look at and if I cannot look at j
I will put minus infinity, so what you do in all the future things you put minus infinity
right, so this can only look at itself this can look at previous word itself up to itself
right cannot look at future token and this is what is done minus infinity right, so
that it is just in the upper triangle you put it to minus infinity, so it cannot look
at future tokens but the things can happen in parallel right, so and you compute your
loss everything right in parallel you do not have to do auto regressively during training
at decoding at inference time you will still have to do in auto regressively one by one,
so this is one thing the self-admission is masked you put a mask minus infinity to the
future tokens, second thing so this is how it will look like the upper triangle will
be set to minus infinity right, the second thing that happens in decoder is that encoder
decoder attention, so that means the decoder will focus on that encoder repentations, so
let us say the other encoder repentations and at some point of decoder I am I have the
output of the self-admission, how would I focus all on the encoder remember, so this
would my query will have to come from here and where will key and value come from because
I have to focus on the encoder the key and value will have to come from here, that means
the key and value are residing here and the query matrix will be here right, so again I
need query key and values right and then query key values and W O everything, so that my
self-attention encoder decoder attention output is also obtained right, so in decoder first
I will have the self-attention output then I will have the encoder decoder attention output
and then I apply feed for pretend, so what is encoder decoder definition very similar
except that the query will come from the decoder and key and value will come from the encoder
right, so you will have again same learnable matrices W Q for encoder decoder W K for encoder
decoder W V for encoder decoder right and then you will also have W O for encoder decoder
same matrices multiple hats all of this will again repeat right except that the key and
value is coming from encoder and query is coming from the decoder right, that is the
only change that happens okay, now in decoding so you will keep on doing self-attention cross
attention cross attention feed forward right and finally across after all the layers you
get the output embedding output embedding, now I want to compute the loss right, I know
my ground tooth is I at the start I my ground tooth is I I want to generate I, so how do
I convert an embedding that is say 512 dimension, how do I use that to compute the loss right,
I know the ground tooth is I, so the way it is done is that I project it to the vocabulary
space my vocabulary space is may be huge 50,000 words 100,000 unique words and I get a distribution
probably distribution I need the distribution for the ground tooth work and I take minus
log probability of the ground tooth work as my loss cross entropy loss, so I keep on accumulating
this so this is minus log probability of I minus log probability of m a student I keep
on accumulating it that becomes my loss and all these parameters that you are seeing here
are trained via this loss, so you keep on accumulating this loss and train all these
parameters via this right, so something like I have this embedding output I have a linear
layer that will project in the vocabulary size right, now these will be some real values
so apply softmax, softmax will convert into probabilities and I take the I have the ground
tooth token, so I take the minus log probability of this the ground tooth token index and that
will become my loss right, it is as simple as that, so softmax is again coming in the
picture for converting the real values into distribution probability distribution from
which you can compute your loss ok, now transformers can also be used as language models what
is a language model you simply predict the next word right, so you see it is very easy,
so once I have the words I have the final, so this because I am predicting the next word
this will come into the decoder transformer only as a decoder, so I will simply use a
transformers as a decoder model and I keep on getting the representation for each word
and wherever I need the next word what I will do, this is a d dimension I convert it to
my vocabulary dimension, so how, so I had an embedding matrix that converted the original
input into embedding dimensions, so to convert a model dimension into vocabulary I use an
embedding layer d cross b right, so I will get a v dimension projection and I get a distribution
from that probabilities and from that I can generate a word right, the word with the highest
probability, so typically that is what is done, so why we use an embedding, so remember
so we did not specify in the beginning, so what will happen, so suppose I have an input
I am a student, so I you can simply feed as a one hot, I is one everything else is zero
in your vocabulary right and then you have an embedding matrix that will take that will
give me the actual embedding for the word I, so this will give me the d dimension, this
v dimension d dimension and this is some d cross v dimension embedding matrix, so this
can also be a learnable parameter in your model, so this embedding matrix, so that given
any word one hot representation you get this embedding right, so this is what is done in
the embedding side, we simply took it as if it is given to us, but you can have this matrix,
now when you want to generate the output at the final decoder you have a d dimension output
right, I want to convert into a vocabulary dimension, so you can see I can again reuse
this matrix, so e transpose this will convert this d to vocabulary dimension, so here it
converted a v to d, now I can convert it from d to v using the transpose of this embedding
and this is what we can call it as an embedding layer right, because in language modeling
what is my task given the sequence till now predict the next word, so I simply predict
the next word right from the output of decoder what is the next word, I take the word with
the highest probability and this becomes my next word right, so now I take the output
at the final token, I multiplied with an embedding layer, I get q logits, I apply softmax, I get
the probabilities, now if you are training I will take the minus log probability of the
correct token, if I am finally doing inference I will take the word with the highest probability
and there are many other decoding methods along with that that one can use right, so
this is how a transformer language model looks like, so suppose this is my i th word, i ferries
embedding, position embedding, I go through multiple layers, get the representation at
the final layer once I get the representation, I apply this unembedding matrix, I apply softmax,
I have the probabilities for all the tokens, I sample a token from that as per the distribution,
so now if you want to look at what are the number of parameters I will have in transformer
encoder decoder, so encoder we saw will be 12 D square into L, L is the number of layers
right because 4 D square in self-attention, 8 D square in the feed forward per layer,
what about decoder, see decoder has again self-attention is must, but number of parameters
do not change because of that, so it will have 4 D square per layer, feed forward again
will have 8 D square, what extra it has, it has encoder decoder attention, so for encoder
decoder it will have again the same thing except that query will reside here and key
and value will be at the encoder output, so you will have n w o, so you will again have
4 D square parameters for the cross-attention, so total you have 16 D square per layer, so
16 D square into L, so that means if you are using encoder decoder architecture for L layers
you may need 12 D square plus 16 D square that is 28 D square parameters per layer right
into L, now if you are simply using a decoder only transformer, how many parameters you
need, so decoder does not need an encoder decoder attention, decoder means there is only decoder,
so you use that when you have a simply language model right, you are simply given the previous
words you are generating the next word, there is no encoder right, so there is no encoder
decoder attention, so decoder only have mask self-attention, it has feed forward network,
that means it has simply 12 D square into number of layers that many parameters, so that means
the number of parameters in encoder only model and decoder only model are the same, but if
you have encoder decoder model, you will have more parameters because of cross-attention
ok.
So, now given this idea about the transformer architecture, let us see how do you pre-train
these architectures and we will see an example from bird, so how do you pre-train, what is
the idea of pre-train right, so in general how does the deep learning typically works,
so let us say I have a task of spam detection right, so that means I have a text and I have
some labels right, so I will pass this text to some neural network and I will train it
to predict the correct label in that spam not spam and I will train its weights right,
so typically start from random weights and I train it to some weights that are fine tuning
or whatever you want to call it, so you use these weights at the inference time to detect
with the detection, the problem is that in NLP there are huge number of applications
and huge number of domains, so I can talk about say customer support application where
I have given being given some E manuals and I have some question I want to answer the
question, so this is a domain of E manuals, I may have legal domain, I have given a contract,
I want to extract certain clauses from that, I may be given financial domain, I want to
extract what is the XPLL tag for each numeral, I may be given biomedical domain where I have
to do what are the proteins genes, what are interactions between that, so you see there
are so many domains, so many applications in each domain, so many languages, if I have
to follow this pattern right, I mean what I have to do for every problem I will start
from scratch right, I will get lot of data and I will get some model, I will get some
model, but this model does not work for any other problem right, so I will start from
scratch, I will get one model for classification right, theta classification, say financial
domain, another model for theta classification in biomedical domain and so on, another model
for Hindi and Bengali and so on, so you will have different models for each domain, each
language and for doing all that you need lot of data and for every task, every domain,
every language you need lot of data right and that is not scalable, I mean how do you
get such huge amount of data right, we are not so cheap, so and that is what is the issue,
I mean so in the new networks, so typically when you have a sentence, I need the word
embeddings, so let us say I can get word vectors directly, but then I have a whole lot of architecture
of the self-prediction and feed forward layer like so many parameters we saw, every task
you need separate data for training all of these will be like huge amount of data required
right, you may need 100 million parallel sentences for each pair, language pair translation,
so right and that means the data I have should be sufficient enough, so that I can learn
all aspect of a language just from the data right, if I do random initialization, so that
is why the idea came, why do I need to do random initialization always right, why cannot
I do something else, so can I not obtain a good enough initialization first and from
there I start for any task right, so this is where the pre-training fine-tuning paradigm
took over, I mean so idea was that okay, so what you do, you take a model start from scratch,
but you pre-train it starting from random rate on some very general data, where you
have abundance right available, so huge data available and you do not need people to label
the data for you right, so what can we task like predict the next one, you do not need
people to tell you what is the next word, you take any Wikipedia article you know what
is the next word from the previous sequence, so I simply train a model to predict the next
word right or something similar and you train it, so that it learns a lot about the language
already and that means and then after that you say okay, now you give me a task like
classification, I will simply change the model around the pre-trained weights and tune it
for classification, sentiment analysis or summarization all these applications, so how
does the field change, so in transfer learning, so I want to train a new network language
model on washed corpus where I do not need human labels right and so I do not need no
human labels required and once I have learned this pretend this, I use this knowledge to
transfer to any target task right and this has become a has been a very successful idea,
so because if I do simply so much learning, I need like millions of examples thousands
of example for every task right and but if you take a language model as a starting point
a pre-trained model, you get much smaller examples, you need much smaller number of
examples to do that, so what is a model learn from pre-training, so text you see what we
are doing, we are taking a large body of text and simply asking model to predict the next
word right, now if I do it over the enormous data like what kind of knowledge the model
can really learn right, so for example let us say this will be one sentence, there can
be canines everywhere, one dog in the front roof and two and you have to predict the next
word dogs, so what do you learn, you learn the plural of dog is dogs right, similarly
here it was not just big, it was enormous right, you need from big how do you get superlative
of big enormous right, the author of a rumor one's own age, so you need you learn what
who is the author, you need real world knowledge while doing next word prediction right, this
is all your training signal, you are training the model to predict wolf after given the
sentence, the doctor told me that predicting the pronoun right, and you can see this can
also introduce biases like you may have lot of data that is telling that here you are
predicting he rather than she and that can also introduce bias in your model that we
hear a lot about, so you are doing a lot of different kind of prediction, the square
root of 4 is 2 right, I mean you are learning also mathematics by doing this prediction,
so that is why language model it is pretend on a huge amount of data, it is doing next
word prediction for all kind of things right, so it is gaining different different kind
of knowledge, grammatical knowledge, mathematical knowledge, domain specific knowledge, names
of entities, names of people associating different things, so it learns all that through pre-training
right, and this can be transferred to in a task right, where it needs that, and this
is what is the pre-training fine-tuning paradigm, so you take you start from scratch right,
you start from scratch and but you do pre-training first things like language modeling, so what
you do you keep on passing a word and predict the next word, if you does not predict you
compute cross entropy loss, update your parameters right, I mean minus loc probability of correct
token, update your parameters, for training you only need the loss right, and then you
feed teacher forcing predict to complete loss, keep on committing loss, train the model,
so theta goes to theta pre-trained, now once you have a pre-trained model, you simply fine
tune it with small number of examples for different task, I want to now the theta fine
tune on classification, theta fine tune on sequence labeling right, and this will be
very small number like something like 1 K example, and this may be like millions and
billions of words, but this is done only once, and this you will do many times right, pre-trained
ones fine tune many times, compare it to where originally what you have to do, if you have
to start from theta and you have to directly go to theta classification, theta sequence
labeling, there you need like thousands of data like 100 K, 1 million right data points,
and this was very difficult to get so much data for each task, each language, each domain,
but now this is easy, so you can simply go from here to pre-trained model, once right
you do pre-training, release the model, and then everyone can go and fine tune right,
so that is what happened with BERT, so people fine tune BERT once, it was released like
it was used hundreds and thousands of times, since it was released, because you can now
simply start from that and tune it for a particular task, now when you talk about pre-trained
they can be two three different architectures, like I can pre-train only decoders, yeah there
is a slight issue here, so you can read like that, so I will tell this is decoder model,
you pre-train only encoders, there is an encoder decoder right, an example of just a decoder
select GPD model, GPD is just a decoder model, Claude is just a decoder model, Lama, Mistal
they are all decoder models, encoder you have the BERT family, BERT is an encoder model,
and encoder decoder you have Flanty 5 and BERT are the examples of encoder decoder models,
so encoder decoder has both, encoders has only encoders, so it will have bi-directional
and decoder will only go from, will only look at the previous token, not the future token,
so this is causal attention right, so three different architectures, and how do I pre-train
them, so I can pre-train encoders only, encoder decoder only, decoders only, so I will start
with just an encoder architecture, I have to understand what is the loss, how do I complete
the loss, so that I can update all my parameters, same for encoder decoder, decoder, and what
is my constraint, I do not need, I do not want to use human labels, I need to use all
the data available on the web, I do not need want to get human labels, just take the data
on the web and compute some loss, update my parameters, now among three which of the,
which architecture do you think is the easiest to pre-train, if you have all the data on
the web, now you may think about it, but it looks like decoder is the easiest, because
in decoder what you will do, you will simply predict the next word, so I can predict the
next word every time, why can't I do that in encoder, because encoder has bi-directional
context, so I cannot predict the next word, because I have to get context from both previous
words and the future words, so I cannot predict the next word, because I already know the
next words here, so how do I use encoder, how do I pre-train encoder, so this was again
very interesting, so you see what will happen, let us say I went to the market, if I want
to pre-train encoder I have to actually feed all of this in the encoder as the embedding,
and the last layer I get the representation of the last layer, and then I have to get
some loss, but all the sentences already known to me, so what will I really predict, so what
is the idea that they did, they said fine, I will use masks, I mean they had this very
nice idea that I will use masks, so yeah before corona times, so this is what, so what was
the masking here, so they said okay, say I went to the store, was the original sentence
in my data, so what did they say okay I have to predict some words, let me remove some
words and mask them, that means the model does not know what is the input, I do not
know they were bent here, I do not know there is store here, so what is the word I will
put there, I will put a mask, a placeholder mask, so that means my input is I mask to
put a mask, okay now I will do my encoding like my self-attention feed forward and all,
I get the final representation, then what will I do, the task is now at the final representation
at this token, you predict what was the input, what should have been the input, the input
should have been bent, at here you predict the input should have been stored, how will
the model figure that out, so idea is that if you have a good contextual representation,
you can know what should have been the word at this particular point, given the surrounding
words, that is the idea, but given the surrounding words you predict what should have been the
word at this position and that is why it is called a masked language model, you are not
predicting the next token, you are predicting the token that you have masked already, right,
so and how exactly they did that, they said okay if I simply do this, if I simply mask
some tokens and predict that, the model may get complicit and say I will only give good
representation whenever there is a mask in and I will predict the word, but otherwise
I will not care, but my huge case will be attached time, you are giving me a sentence,
I want to get a good contextual representation, right, I will not have mask at the run time,
so what will I do, so they say okay to ensure that the model gives a good representation
for all the words, they said okay to randomly sometimes I will replace a word with a random
word, you see I pitch that to the store, I mean pitch that does not make sense in the
sentence and I will predict what is the output, that means the model should figure out at
this point they should have been went and sometime I will keep the word as it is and
I still predict, so that the model has to make a good representation at all the words,
right, including mask or even if there is a normal word it has to make a good representation,
so they did it like some 15 percent of tokens total out of this 15 percent 80 percent times
they masked, that means overall 12 percent times a token was masked, 10 percent of times
it was rib based with a random token that means 15 into 10, 1.5 percent and 10 percent
of the times you leave the word unchanged but you still figure that out, so that means
again 1.5 percent time out of 15, so that is how they and they will only compute loss
for this 15 percent of the tokens, right, so that is for the BERT model and BERT model
they had released like a base model, a large model, base model had 12 layers, 768 model
dimension, 12 attention heads, 110 million parameters and BERT large had 12, 24 layers,
1024 dimension, 16 attention heads and 340 million parameters and it used a vocabulary
of 30,000, now this is very small because it is used the idea byte pair encoding, so
it did not use the words but the sub words, so it used the sub words, so a long word will
be broken into its sub words to represent in the vocabulary, right and it was trained
on book corpus and English Wikipedia you see already 3.3 million words and it was done
on a that time it took like roughly 4 days on 64 TPU chips, but then I mean you pretend
only once and then it was fined in like many, many times, so yeah another view of seeing
the word BERT model, so you you have the sentence or is the sentence in your data you mask some
tokens and you play some token by some random words and you predict what should have been
the word at these positions after you get that good representation and from there you
have the loss minus the probability of the correct token, from the loss you train all
your parameters, so you do the sufficient number of times you have the good parameters
with you, right and then once you have the parameters then you can use that for any task
later on, like in the paper what they showed they can use for task like sentence pair classification
you are given two sentence classified whether they are similar sentence whether they are
contradicting each other and so on, how do you feed two sentence they said ok you have
a CLS token sentence 1, separator sentence 2 and you get the embedding for all the tokens
you predict the label, how do you do classification I have a specific token CLS token I feed the
entire sentence token 1 to n and for the CLS token I will predict the representation and
from that I will predict the class, right and similarly for question answering I will
CLS token I put question, separator, paragraph and predict what is the span in the paragraph
that answers my question and I may have some sentence tagging task where I am given a sentence
each word I have to predict what is the label for that word, so remember we talked about
we will first pretend it, so bird was a pretending part but to use it for any of these tasks
you have to do fine tuning, so you are pretending followed by fine tuning, so what is this fine
tuning involved right, so pretending already gave you the all the weights but now I want
to fine tune it for a particular task, so let us say I am doing single sentence classification,
so what will happen I am given a sentence and I have to classify into one of the labels
let us say I have three labels positive negative neutral, so I have a sentence, so let us say
token 1 to token n, this is a sentence, now in bird while pre-turning they had introduced
a specific token called CLS token, so you put CLS before the center sequence, right,
so this is your input, now you went go through the entire transform a bird pre-tent model,
so after the last layer you will get a the same dimension output, so bird used the model
dimension of 768, so you have a 768 dimension output at for each of the input, right and
the CLS token was specially designed for classification, so what you will do, so from the 768 dimension
CLS token embedding, now you try to predict the class, so that means I just need to predict
use a fully connected layer 768 cross 5 that cross 3 there are three labels that will convert
the 768 dimension into 3 class output, right and you do softmax, right over there you get
the probabilities and you have the minus law probability for the correct class, so I only
read this additional 768 cross 3 parameters and then I can find in my model, now you have
option whether you want to fine tune and architecture also, so people do that sometime
or you want to leave it as it is only train this additional parameters, right and that
is how you do for all other tasks like pair by sentence classification, there is some
pattern by which you feed it CLS token, sentence 1, separators, sentence 2 and predict for the
class labels at C, sequence labeling you are predicting for every token, so every token
you have the representation and then you predict a label for every token, right, so you will
have the number of parameters additional parameters you need will depend on what are the different
tags that you have, so if you are using 50 different tags I will use 768 dimension and
convert it to 50 dimension, 768 cross 50 that is how I can use some additional parameters
to fine tune for sequence labeling task K times dh, dh is the model dimension and K is
the number of tags that you have, part of speech tagging very similar you get the representation
you apply a layer that will convert the representation to the number of tags dimension, so all of
this becomes very easy once you have a between model you only need a small amount of data
and they did a benchmarking over this standard blue architecture and that had multiple tasks
like linguistic accessibility, COLA task, sentiment analysis task, paraphrase detection
task, sentence similarity task, analy task and so on and they try to find out what are
the performance of birth compared to the previous architectures that were there, so what they
found that across tasks the birth base and large models but outperforming the previous
models that were proposed, right and you see I mean on an average they are much high improvements
that compared to the previous models and that is where the birth model became very very
popular, the same model could be used for all the tasks that you have in the benchmark,
right and this was simply pretend encoders, right, pretend encoder you can use it for
any classification task, sequence labeling task, sentence payer task, question answering,
right everything, now the other two ways you can do pretending is if I take encoder decoder
models or the decoder models, now encoder decoders if I take the question is how do
I convert an input sentence, see in the data I just have sentences into some input and
some output, right there are various ways of doing that, so how exactly they did this
they said okay let us say this is my sentence, thank you for inviting me to your party last
week, so I have to convert some input and some output from here, so what will my input
they said okay let me corrupt this sentence, so I removed something, so I removed foreign
writing put it by some sentinel X, removed large put by sentinel Y, so this will be
my input to the model, what is the output, output will be what should come under X what
should come under Y, so what will be X will have foreign writing Y should have last and
then you end with G, so now once you input output you know what to fill in encoder, this
will go into encoder and this will be the predicted by the decoder, right, so once you
know what is predicted by the decoder you can compute the loss, decoder loss is easy
minus the probability of the correct token, so keep on computing the loss for the decoder
add it and train all your parameters, so like that you can take huge data and train your
encoder decoder architecture, so this is what was T5 model, so text to text transfer transformer
they train in that manner and then they showed they can use it for different different tasks
like I can use for translation, I put source at the input, target at the output, I can
use it even for things like I have two sentences, find out similarity, my decoder can even generate
a number, similarity is 3.8, right, I have a sentence at the input, a document as the
input and you summarize it, you generate the summary at the output, so encoder decoder architecture,
so and then finally decoder is the simplest, training decoder is the simplest because you
want to simply predict the next word, so you take the data and keep on predicting the next
word, so I feed the data W1 predict W2, teacher forcing, put it back predict next word, so
keep on doing that, I do not need to do any changes and I can compute loss for all 100
percent of the tokens, that I was not able to do with encoder models, every token predict
next word, compute loss and use that, right, so and the GPT model this came very same same
time as BERT roughly, so very similar architecture, it had slightly more parameters, why because
they used slightly higher vocabulary, so they had roughly 10 K more tokens in vocabulary
and 10 K into 768, if you do this will be roughly like 7 million difference from the
BERT parameters, so this was the GPT model and then slowly all other models like GPT,
GPT 2, GPT 3, chat GPT and all came in, right, now I am not going into details about the
other architectures, the focus of this lecture was mainly to introduce the transformer architecture
and tell you what is pre-training and briefly discuss what is a BERT architecture, right,
so where you pre-train encoders, so we talked about all these interesting ideas, I hope
this became clear to you, so overall to conclude, so transformer architecture along with the
pre-training idea has transformed the field of AI, particular in the field of NLP and
this has been backbone for most of the foundation models that we see in text, vision, multimodal
and so on, so with that I will end now and we can take some questions.
Could you please explain where the dimension 1 cross dv changing to 1 cross h dv, right,
so what I will do, I will just use one of the slide where there is some space to explain
this, so let me know what happens in self-attention, so in single hat, so you have h hats, so think
about one hat, right, one hat, you are what you are doing, you are taking a query key
and value and your output is a weighted average of all the values and each values of dimension
dv, so single hat you have dv dimension output, right, dv is the dimension of the value, now
think about having h hats, so each hat has dv dimension output, now what do you do with
that, you simply concatenate them one after another, right, so output of first hat, second
hat, hatchet hat and you concatenate them one after another, so how many dimensions you
will have, you will have h dv, so that is how the 1 cross dv from a single attention
hat got transformed to 1 cross h dv for h attention hats, right, I hope that is clear.
Why do we consider taking dq is equal to dk, is it by convention, very good question you
see, so why do we take dq is equal to dk, see depends on how you are computing your
self-attention, so what is the self-attention formulaism, so you take a vector, so you take
two words x i and x j, I get the key value and query from the for i th word, the query
key and value from the j th word, right, now for self-attention let us say I take from
the i th word and j th word, query comes from the i th word and the key comes from the j
th word, so that means I will do q i dot q j divide by square root of dk, now I am doing
a dot root of query from i and key of j, now what is the dimension of query i, so query
i's dimension is dq, so q i is dimension dq and k j is dimension dk, so if I am doing
a dot product they too have to have the same dimensions, that is why we take dq is equal
to dk, and I mean of course there are other formulations of attention that were not so
popular in transformers where you put some multiplicative matrix in between, so you can
have q i, k j and put some matrix in between, now if you put a matrix in between what can
happen you can now use the matrix to change the dimensions, so then you may be allowed
to use different dimensions, but if you use the standard self-attention framework you have
to have the same dimensions, so that you can use a dot product between them, no other questions.
Okay then, so yeah thank you all for participating and we will have a hands on session following
this, thank you.